they are all struggling that's the stuff
in infectious wards and every hospital
they are in the frontline they're
treating and saving people and they
prevent a lot of prevention and I'm sure
that all of the Russians would
appreciate what they're doing and there
are other industries that are working
hard I'd like to sincerely thank all of
you without any exception and I'd like
to say thank you to the volunteers all
the people who are not indifferent who
know that they can do their part those
who have followed all the guidelines
from medical specialists who take care
of the health of their relatives and
their surroundings the non-working week
that was introduced across the country
and self-isolation regime for many
regions have bought us time for a lot of
preventive action to mobilize all the
authorities and bodies to ramp up our
resources in our health care system to
fund the N pandemic in the most
efficient way using our own experience
and the best practices from other
countries now what is critically
important so far we have taken care of
the elderly we have not seen any year
our bursts of epidemic outbreak of
epidemics in educational establishments
in preschool facilities or universities
and schools but what's next
I'd like to one emphasize when we take
further action we still need to be aware
that the threat is still over as
specialists say the peak of the epidemic
is not yet over
this is why I have taken the decision to
extend the non-working time until the
end of the month until the 30th of April
and that's a paid leave the workers will
still get their salaries the situation
is changing and a lot of municipalities
in order of regents the situation varies
we have a very huge country vast
territories different density of
population and there are regions where
coronavirus has created serious threat
for the people take Moscow despite the
actions of the federal authorities the
city hall we have not reversed the trend
and there are regions a fewer and fewer
regions unfortunately where we haven't
seen a single case of covered 19 so
somewhere we need to take more severe
action
well elsewhere remaining alert local
targeted action would suffice this is
why the heads of Russian regions at my
direction will get additional powers by
the end of the week they will have to
identify specific set of preventive
action region specific measures to take
care of the health and safety of the
people and also the sustainability of
the economy and the critical
infrastructure now I would like to
reiterate that once again the regions
need to take stock of the reality on the
ground and take an appropriate decision
on the rest isolation regime what kind
of
local action they would take to comply
with the decree of the Russian president
which institutions and bodies and
factories need to stop and which can't
continue to go on providing for the
safety of the people just like before
all the authorities will continue
working all the essential factories and
plants need to work
grocery stores pharmacies and all those
who provide for the lives of the people
now if we need to introduce further
restrictions for scientific educational
establishments so all for in case so far
any plants or factories the region's we
have to get approval from the federal
authorities we need to work hand in hand
both at the federal regional and
municipal level and this is why every
word asked all of my assistants in the
regions to connect coordinates the
activities we all need to get the
information to Thea Coordination
Committee at the government it will be
processed analyzed and taken into
account in the decision-making process
and the actions of the regional
authorities will need to be definitely
coordinated with our health care
authorities we need to take care of the
safety and health of the people that's
our priority number one
given the if we see any future
developments we might take further
action we will adjust with the number of
taste that we need to stay in isolation
the absolute we can roll it back so that
there will be fewer days when we stayed
on paid leave now once again as we
permit these measures we need to
remember that it's as important today to
keep our jobs and the livelihoods of our
people that's our general priority for
the
government for the region for the
business community we need to provide
for efficient stable economy that's the
foundation that will help us to resolve
the key challenges we're facing
particularly in health care my fellow
Russians I'd like to ask you to continue
to follow the guidelines of the doctors
and the authorities take care of your
health and the health of your relatives
our shared responsibility and mutual
support is increasingly important this
was a short time just one week but we
saw that when we realize the importance
the threat we can mitigate the risks I'm
certain that we'll continue to act as
concerted as before and we need to take
preventive action we need to get one
step ahead of the virus I wish you all
the best and good health
take care
there again Lucia